ciao a voi un nuovissimo video
oggi si parla ancora di natale ma
soprattutto i parenti i parenti a natale
una una cosa che accomuna tutti noi
ecco sono sicura che guardando questo
video ciascuno di voi riconoscere almeno
quei due tre quattro cinque patetico 5
10 parenti
ricordatevi di lasciarvi un commento qui
sotto invece devi sapere quali di questi
parenti
avete in famiglia e ci vediamo alla fine
del video che come diciamoci la verità
l'unica cosa bella
notare bene e mangiare mangiare bere
bere mangiare e basta questo vino
cordate che la fodera alla parola jean
questo papa ma vabbè poi c è stato un
bravo a scuola
voglio farti un regalo particolare però
non dire niente a nonna nato stanno non
duo dimona dare prima grazie mille
grazie mi sono stufata basta tipo giorno
ti poni visto che la nota e cucino io
non solo la mostra schiano va bene
carissima ciao ma come stai
tutto bene grazie a mi hanno aiutato
tutto il giorno a cucinare a
sparecchiare mi stanno lavando i piatti
sono perché mi rilasso voglio fare un
brindisi annachiara perché non so se lo
sapevate ancona è poi diventata
signorina e poi facciamo anche un
brindisi alla claudia perché si spera
che si trovi un uomo prima insomma che
signorina non lo scempio che si tesoro
questo avviene no i regali si aprono va
bene hai capito adesso poi la sembra il
noi la testina ma niente confronto alla
mia vita della formula mi hanno trovato
prima le emorroidi vuole lunga sarà
melosi perché mangiava la salamella poi
il turismo che faceva aria
un gradino sopra il racconto un altro è
il cognome babbo natale ovvero un bello
che richiama vice qua altra nota il
collo vero un dentista mangiare la pasta
al tonno per un pavimento era una brutta
nera ma cosa specchio sempre attaccato
telefonino ciao alla classe thai già
noto ai lavori eco spettacolo ceo e poi
portato a pascolare leva che avevamo
latte buono con le porcherie che
mangiate voialtri oggi la cellulite non
venivano in italia 2 ma poi parlano poco
si pianta la capanna che sta qua c'è
anemica ciao stato già buono brava il
gatto era buono mancava un po di sale
poi la ricetta originale quella che
faccio io anche la pancetta e cumino e
ci metto anche il taleggio che si fonde
dentro però qua brava buono buono cosa
vorresti dire che non sono bravo quanto
te vuoi un premio per essere la buca più
prova nella famiglia brava brava ma gli
applausi buona ma lanciate proprio una
cosa vuoi farmi fare brutta figura
davanti alla mamma e almeno mi sono
impegnata e basta me ne vado
sentite questa ciao mi siede un piccolo
favore non è un gioco di veti ha visto
soffrire per qualcosa mi dice che sta
arrivando una benedizione
se credi in dio manda questo messaggio a
20 persone vista puri non ignorare ve lo
mando subito non ignorate la banca
mi è arrivata 83 anni zitella e ma
felice senza problemi senza delusioni
perché gli uomini pensano a solana cota
sono tutti i maiali negli eau solite
cornuti marina cielo di rosanna al
telefono davanti chi vuole fare gli
auguri monovolume compatta di una prima
ballerina del bagaglino
io la fa bene a prati sorelle poi
approdate lo zio luigi nel merito date
stimato in frantumi
sennò questore era meglio della belen
buon appetito affiancati con 100
centesimi signore grazie come presidente
vediamo insieme in be great hanno
regalato andava mi ha regalato l'iphone
uomo e ho pagato mille euro fatti sono
contentissimo non ne vado gratis in iraq
ancora di venire ha fatto quando grida
oggi mori e poi bene ho fatto la vostra
ha mai comprato pure bella e quindi
adesso i 16 anni tu sei un congresso ata
lo sa
tante le zie 13 perché tipo di tanto ben
di chili che prendi a questa età
inserito guerra allora come un'ala
[Musica]
destra tirato conosciamo che si scivola
a sciabola nei vagoni ma aspetta che vi
racconto una cosa
l'altro giorno suonata cartella di
rigori con giorgio mi ha fatto una foto
con il cartello dietro bellissima l'ho
subito messo su instagram e e ho preso
12 like non era mai successo né a
proposito adesso vi faccio un set con
l'albero e non abbiamo mangiato a
abbiamo bevuto
torniamo un uomo a
adesso dove sono carmela mesi lupi ve ne
siete amati
eccoci purtroppo arrivati alla fine del
video spero tantissimo che mi sia
piaciuto e fatemi sapere quale di questi
personaggi questi parenti vi è piaciuto
di più è come al solito se non l'avete
ancora fatto ricordatevi di iscrivervi
al canale e se volete essere aggiornati
su tutto tutto tutto tutti i miei video
attivate le notifiche cliccando la
campanella vicino al costo di iscrizione
mettete i tanti stili reich e
soprattutto seguitemi su tutte le altre
social instagram facebook e musicali
adoro ciao
[Musica]